I’m almost as embarrassed by the word spirituality
as every other atheist.
It’s not – I’m not comfortable with
my use of it.
The problem is – and this is a problem you
almost never encounter in English.
We just don’t have a good word for this
domain.
We just do not have a good word for the project
of taking seriously the notion that you could
become like Jesus or become like the Buddha
or become someone who inhabits the far end
of the positive side of the continuum of human
psychology and human well-being.
And someone who can have really radical insights
into the nature of consciousness by virtue
of a disciplined practice like meditation.
So to talk about things like awe and well-being
and love and positive psychology and happiness,
that doesn’t get at how deep and rarified
this project can be.
It also doesn’t link it to the traditional
context in which people have pursued similar
projects.
So there is a point of contact between what
I’m talking about and, you know, what a
Tibetan Lama is doing in a cave for five years.
I mean it’s very explicit.
Most of these teachings come out of traditions
like Buddhism.
So while I argue that we have to get out of
the religion business and the doctrines that
have framed most people’s discussion of
these experiences are as unwarranted as I’ve
always said.
There is no alternative term for the efforts
that people can make through meditation or
psychedelics or some other means to really
transform their consciousness and have insight
into the – it’s intrinsic selfless nature.
And it’s inconvenient but I feel like the
other words that are available are even spookier,
something like mysticism, you know, or more
specific like contemplation, the contemplative
life.
I use contemplative a fair amount but again
that doesn’t get at for most people what
the subject matter is.
So for better or worse I’m just – I’m
trying to rehabilitate the word spirituality.
I mean one burden I think we have is to reclaim
good and powerful words no matter how they’ve
been misused in the past, no matter what the
inconvenient details of their etymology is.
So I would say spirituality is one of those
words.
But a word like evil is also spooky for many
people.
It’s felt that evil is a holdover from religion.
When religious people talk about evil they’re
thinking about things like Satan and a force
that is somehow not to be understood in scientific
or naturalistic terms.
And it’s thought, I think, rightly that
once we understand psychopathy at the level
of the brain fully we will have a discussion
of evil that will seem to erode any basis
for using this spooky word.
But I think to lose the word evil would be
unfortunate and would disempower smart people
from making strong moral claims and fighting
a war of ideas on this front.
And so we need potent words.
We just need to be precise about how we use
them and the kinds of experiences that merit
their use.